[Musique]
le quartier des buis c'est dangereux at
il raison claude françois sommer cet
habitant de valentigney de se méfier du
quartier populaire de votre commune qui
concentrent 15 à 20% de la population
alors le quartier des buis bientôt
depuis 30 ans fait l'objet de mesures de
politique de la ville de dispositifs
particuliers pour accompagner la
mutation du logement social la mutation
de la population qui occupent ces
quartiers effectivement dans ce quartier
nous avons des problèmes d'ordre social
nous avons aussi des problèmes de
sécurité je crois qu'il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles telles qu'elles
le sont en tout cas moi j'ai rencontré
encore récemment des habitants des bus
qui se sentent abandonnés par par
l'habile qu'aujourd'hui on prend pas en
compte les difficultés auxquelles ils
sont confrontés au quotidien c'est les
questions de propreté c'est les
questions de l'éclairage public qui
n'est pas réparé en temps et en heure
ces problèmes des attroupements c'est le
problème des dégradations
il faut qu'on soit présence d'autres
formes que ce soit en termes de
prévention d'accompagnement des familles
mais aussi ci a besoin en terme de
répression pour effectivement que chacun
puisse vivre en paix dans l'ensemble des
victimes en matière de sécurité quelles
sont vos propositions
alors tout d'abord on se rend compte que
les personnes dont beaucoup de choses à
dire en matière de sécurité ou
d'insécurité et qu'elle ne trouve pas
dans les différentes administrations et
compris celle de la mairie une réponse
dont un projet phare dans notre
programme qui sera la maison de la
tranquillité donc ça sera un espace qui
pourra être amené à régler dans les
problèmes de sécurité de manière
coopérative avec les différentes police
et justice dans les problèmes de
quotidiens du vivre ensemble
les gens pourront poser leurs
difficultés pourront trouver une réponse
nous nous engageons à mettre en place ce
qui manque beaucoup sur la vident des
formes de médiation pour pouvoir aussi à
régler les problèmes
philippe gautier
les bruits se sentent les habitants des
bruits se sentent abandonnés par la
municipalité a dit claude françoise
saulnier oui avez-vous à lui répondre
oui bah c'est un sentiment que les
personnes peuvent partager
pour autant les autres tranquillité bon
que c'est votre choix c'est pas c'est
pas vraiment le mien en termes de
sécurité
je suis plutôt preneur d'une système de
prévention pu côté plutôt que de
répression
mais lorsqu'on prend le système dans sa
globalité
il faut quand même amené une réponse la
réponse de la police me semble est
adapté parce que la police tient avant
tout du dialogue c'est avant tout du
contact et malheureusement lorsque je
suis arrivé avec mon équipe en 2014 il
n'y avait qu'un seul policier municipal
pour une ville de 11 mille habitants ça
me paraît un peu faiblard nous avons mis
en place quatre personnes
aujourd'hui on a un effectif de quatre
personnes avec une nouvelle un poste de
police municipale sur le côté de la
mairie et je dois plutôt rebondir sur
nos thématiques c est non pas à
l'endroit où vous aviez choisi à
l'époque qui était une cellule
commerciale qui avait pignon sur rue et
aujourd'hui vu qu'on a discuté aussi des
commerces un habitant kiseki n'est pas
de commerce
mais à cet endroit là commerce est
apparu je préfère cent fois mieux voir
un commerce que noir un peu licites la
police municipale donc c'est surtout à
mon avis à un passage de dialogue qui
est extrêmement important est que les
gens ne se sentent pas en décalage
effectivement une modification qui va
s'opérer dans le programme
c'est d'amener trois adultes relais
supplémentaire parce qu'aujourd'hui avec
les problématiques de dijon voilà la
sous préfecture va mettre en place et va
dégager justement sur les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville des
financements croisés qui vont être
extrêmement important pour les communes
attendez vous citez dijon là vous parlez
de des soucis qu'il ya depuis quelques
jours avec
la guerre de territoire l'insécurité
c'est l'insécurité au global moi je ne
vise aucune communauté parce que c'est
pas du tout le but du propos c'est
aujourd'hui un financement ou nous dit
ce type de problème peut aussi arriver
chez nous certainement pas non non non
je ne crois pas j'ai pas quoi alors je
suis désolé je n'ai pas compris le lien
avec dijon du coup non c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est que du fait que des
problématiques sur une ville en franche
comté
il ya des flèches et dont on croise des
des financements justement pour amener
justement ce qu'on appelle des
dispositifs d'adultes relais pour amener
de la médiation au sein des quartiers
donc valentine vient peur enfin aurait
tort du moins de s'en passer
et justement à mener ce sentiment enfin
amener ce contact pour baisser ce
sentiment d'insécurité claude françois
sonier la municipalité actuelle a
effectivement multiplier par quatre le
nombre de policiers municipaux des
policiers qui sont armés passent dans le
passé de un policier à 4 non létales
arme non létale est ce que ça vous
pensez que c'est une bonne chose est-ce
que vous revenez dessus si vous êtes élu
maire est ce que vous développez la
police municipale j'aimerais vous
entendre là dessus alors effectivement
l'arrivée de monsieur gautier la mairie
n'y avait plus qu'un policier municipal
mais il y avait trois postes de
policiers qui qui était ouvert et
monsieur gautier le caecum d'où toute la
difficulté garder ses agents - ces
fonctionnaires qui tourne beaucoup au
niveau de leur poste mais n'a entendu il
n'est pas question d'alléger la police
municipale et si besoin s'il ya
nécessité dans le cadre de notre maison
de la tranquillité qui va être aussi un
espace on va mener un diagnostic bien
connaître les problèmes et mettre en
phase les réponses adaptées s'il ya
besoin de créer un ou plusieurs postes
nous nous donnerons les moyens pour ce
faire on met une petite vous l'avait
chiffrée ça par exemple ce que vous
dites cia
un besoin si un besoin alors ça va être
une question de dire que s'est ouvert
dans votre programme décidé là dessus
s'est ouvert dans notre programme
aujourd'hui je ne mesure pas
suffisamment cette dimension que seul un
maire à sa disposition en matière de
statistique de sécurité de fait et c'est
pour pouvoir dire bien delta il manque
deux ou trois postes
donc c'est bien un dossier qui va être
ouvert et qui va qui va s'ouvrir au même
titre que la présence peu je ne parle
pas de dispositif mais de personnes dans
leurs fonctions éducatives dans leurs
fonctions d'animation dans leurs
fonctions de médiation dans tous les
quartiers de la ville ce sera des
actions qui seront renforcés qu'elles
aient un caractère culturel qu elle un
caractère sportif ou autre ça fait
partie de notre projet